let's go next to our caller from the
three one zero area code who's calling
today from three one zero well that
would be me David and who is this Mark
Victor mark Victor go ahead
I was wondering your thoughts on this
Ukrainian situation and x how many
different countries do you potentially
think you know trump could be meddling
in how many countries is trump meddling
in I have no idea I have no idea I mean
I think it's probably more than two but
I really I couldn't say for sure okay
well thank you very much all right very
good thank you for the call I hope I
hope that that was informative let's go
next to our caller from the nine five
one area code caller from 951 who is
this where are you calling from
Dave is that me yes it is oh my gosh Wow
okay hi my name is Corrine I'm a black
college student I go to Cal State Los
Angeles I'm currently in Los Angeles
right now um I'm actually a big fan of
your show becoming a member very soon
please look after me anyway my question
is I would really like your insights or
maybe your speculation on kind of this
hypothetical political situation I've
been thinking about is that okay yeah
okay so let's just say Bernie or Warren
becomes the 2020 presidential they win
the 2020 presidential election and they
become like yay one of the most
progressive presidents with country
scene in the modern era yep assuming
that their policies that they're
pursuing assuming that they will pursue
the policies that they campaign on what
is the likelihood of them actually
enacting these progressive policies with
a let's say democratically controlled
houses
even though most it most of the
Democrats in the Senate and the house
are lean more corporate yeah so Corrine
you're you're asking a really good
question
and it's so important to understand this
no president no matter how much we like
or dislike their policy agenda
accomplishes any significant portion of
what they say they are going to do Trump
is an acute example I mean he's done
almost nothing right he he hasn't fixed
trade he hasn't built the wall he hasn't
done healthcare he's done like nothing
but even president where we like their
ideas like Bernie or Warren in a in a
really optimistic scenario where they
have both the House and Senate maybe for
for two years of their presidency maybe
for four years you know maybe for six
it's very rare that you have a president
who is there for two terms that has the
House and Senate on their side for all
eight years of their term even then you
only get some things done partially
because even people in your own party
don't necessarily agree like for example
the division in the Democratic Party
elector in the Democratic Party elected
officials about health care and because
Republicans do have tools to obstruct no
matter what so I think it's really
important that we all just know and it
sounds like you know it current from
your question that the the policy
platform of the person we select is a
starting point and hopefully they can do
some things but no president gets it all
done the more ambitious the less likely
it is to get done this is a reality this
is how the system is developed with
checks and balances and having to get
through a lot to really make big change
and we just have to recognize that we
have to understand that when we evaluate
the success of a presidency Kareem
listen I don't know if you're using
building blocks or something like that
but it's very loud gotcha gotcha so yeah
you're thinking about all that stuff
current if I can just ask you one more
follow up really quick if that's okay
sure um so today's born Bernie or Warren
get their get their agenda through
Congress right what is the likelihood of
their if their laws going unchallenged
by like a right-wing group and then
being struck down below
of transport appointees that it's so
hard to say because it depends on the
type of thing that you're talking about
if something gets through Congress it is
a much more difficult path to getting it
struck down like bike by a court we saw
that with Obamacare in in many ways
although there were some success it
really just depends you know things done
by executive order can pretty pretty
often be undone by the next executive
order so that's different but it's too
it's too general a question to be able
to answer it with any specificity
Corinne thank you for the call I
appreciate it and I hope to hear from
you again if you're holding don't hang
up because I'm taking a very quick break
and then going right back to the phones